can change all. Hey guys, it's Joel. Welcome to the Taproot Therapy Therapy Collective podcast. And one of the things that a lot of people have requested in the break that I talk about is borderline personality disorder. And I'm not like a BPD expert, so I kind of resisted that topic. I treat a lot of borderlines. I like treating borderlines.
可以改变一切。大家好，我是乔尔。欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。在休息期间，很多人要求我谈谈边缘型人格障碍。我并不是边缘型人格障碍（BPD）方面的专家，所以我一直有点抗拒这个话题。我治疗过很多边缘型人格障碍患者，我也喜欢治疗他们。
I don't really love it as a diagnosis. I think it's kind of useless. So I'll say that I treat a lot of people that fall into the, have been diagnosed with borderline personality disorder. the way that it is used. I don't really think works very well, so I'm not, yeah, anyway, soft critic of a lot of things. And one of the things about BPD, your borderline personality disorder is it's part of something that used to be, I guess what you would call the Axis 2 and the DSM4, and they got rid of the axes.
我其实并不喜欢把它当作一种诊断。我觉得它有点没用。所以我得说，我治疗过很多被诊断为边缘型人格障碍的人。我认为目前这种使用方式效果并不好，所以我，是的，总之，我是很多事物的温和批评者。关于边缘型人格障碍，它曾经属于 DSM-4 中的第二轴（Axis 2），但后来他们取消了轴的概念。
And they replaced them with, well, nothing, I guess. But what was nice about those is that they kind of grouped histrionic personality disorder, narcissistic personality disorder, and borderline personality disorder, and a couple of others together in this way that was useful because they share features a lot of the time. And one of the things that was helpful to me when I was in the way, school and I was learning about a personality disorder is you go to social work school and you read
他们用……嗯，我想说用什么都没取代。但这些轴的好处在于，它们将表演型人格障碍、自恋型人格障碍、边缘型人格障碍以及其他几种障碍归为一类，这种分类很有用，因为它们在很多时候具有共同特征。我在读研学习人格障碍时，有一件事对我很有帮助，那就是当你去读社会工作研究生院时，你会阅读……
the book that they assign and then you go in and you talk about it and you listen to the lecture and you take a test on what you read or whatever and um and they told us before we took the test for the personality disorders especially the cluster B they told us when you read these you're going to say oh my god I have all of them because we all do all of these things some of the time you know a narcissist may do that but We all do it because we all get pulled into these deflection and defense mechanisms. And so maybe some is smarter than me or they're more wealthy than me. And so I talk about a thing that I own that's nice that I know they don't have or I talk about a thing that I know that I know about.
他们指定的书，然后去上课，听讲座，并为你所读的内容参加考试。在参加人格障碍（尤其是 B 组人格障碍）的考试前，他们告诉我们：当你读到这些内容时，你会说“天哪，我全都有”，因为我们所有人有时都会表现出这些行为。你知道，自恋者可能会那样做，但我们所有人都会这样做，因为我们都会陷入这些偏转和防御机制中。所以，也许有人比我聪明，或者比我富有。于是，我就谈论一件我拥有的好东西，我知道他们没有，或者谈论一件我知道的事情。
I'm not a narcissist because I'm not doing that all the time. But I still did it. It's still bad. I may be just so desperate to not deal with something, to not know how to handle a part of my emotional experience that I aggravate my wife and I pull her into my anger so that we're angry together and I'm not alone. That doesn't mean that I'm borderline.
我不是自恋者，因为我不会一直那样做。但我确实那样做了。这仍然是不好的。我可能只是太绝望了，不想处理某件事，不知道如何处理我情感体验的某一部分，以至于我激怒了我的妻子，把她拉进我的愤怒中，这样我们就能一起愤怒，我就不会感到孤独了。这并不意味着我是边缘型人格障碍。
You know, I might just need attention really badly because I don't know to express how alone I am. And I do this thing that means that people pay attention to me. that's kind of crazy or inappropriate, that doesn't mean that I have histrionic personality disorder, you know, so on and so on. But the thing about it is that the conception that I have now of like what a true, what I would, you know, call a personality disorder, I try not to be pathologizing as a clinician, but what I would conceptualize as a dysregulated personality is when someone has no room
你知道，我可能只是非常需要关注，因为我不知道如何表达我有多孤独。我做了一些事情，让人们关注我，这有点疯狂或不恰当，但这并不意味着我患有表演型人格障碍，以此类推。但关键在于，我现在对所谓的“真正的人格障碍”的构想——作为临床医生，我尽量不去病理化——我将其概念化为一种失调的人格，即当一个人在防御机制下……
for a sense of self or an identity under the defense mechanism. because the whole personality has been replaced with a personality game about inferiority, about attention seeking, about attachment, about loneliness. And there's no room for an authentic self. And that means that I have to switch identities all the time. It means that I don't really know who I am. A long time ago, I was doing therapy with somebody, and they were doing brain spotting. and they were someone who had gotten that personality disorder diagnosis from a lot of other people.
没有空间容纳自我感或身份认同。因为整个人格已经被一种关于自卑、寻求关注、依恋、孤独的人格游戏所取代。没有空间容纳真实的自我。这意味着我必须一直切换身份。这意味着我真的不知道我是谁。很久以前，我正在为某人做治疗，他们正在进行脑部扫描（brain spotting）。他们是那种从很多人那里得到过人格障碍诊断的人。
And I told them, you know, I don't really think that way. You meet criteria for some other things. You know, I try and you give you the least pathologizing diagnosis that's accurate. And I don't know that you meet criteria for that now. I think if we deal with trauma, that that will come down. But they definitely had that thing where they were trying to figure out what other people wanted so that they could be that. all the time. And I could have pointed that out.
我告诉他们，你知道，我真的不那样想。你符合其他一些诊断标准。你知道，我尽量给出最准确且最不具病理化的诊断。我不知道你现在是否还符合那个标准。我认为如果我们处理了创伤，那个症状就会减轻。但他们确实有一种试图弄清楚别人想要什么，以便让自己成为那种人的倾向，一直都是这样。我本可以指出这一点。
And they would have said, oh, no, that's not true because I disagree with people or whatever. It's a deeply held implicit emotional belief in the brainstem, you know, in the subcortical brain about how we make predictions about what we need to survive,
他们会说，哦，不，那不是真的，因为我不同意别人的观点，或者诸如此类。这是一种深植于脑干的、隐含的情感信念，你知道，是在皮层下大脑中，关于我们如何预测生存所需的东西，
not a conscious understanding, not a conscious awareness. I mean, some, and so pointing out that that was happening, it never would have worked. But one of the things during brain spotting, this person had a experience where they said, I realized that I was angry with you because I wanted you to tell me
而不是一种有意识的理解，不是一种有意识的觉知。我是说，有些是。所以指出这一点正在发生，是永远不会奏效的。但在脑部扫描过程中，这个人有一次经历，他们说：我意识到我生你的气，是因为我想要你告诉我……
what to do and you were just telling me to look at the pointer. And you wouldn't tell me what you wanted me to do. And I was so panicked because I needed to be what you needed and you didn't need anything. And then I felt a snap and I became separate from you and I realized I'm my own person. I can do what I want. And then I felt another snap. And then I became separate from everyone in the world and I became my own person. And I realized I'm able to just do what I want. And I said, that's great. I appreciate that insight. That's really beautiful. But I didn't, they felt something, you know, like Eugene Glendon would say in the felt sense, or a neuroscientist would say in the interoceptive.
该做什么，而你只是让我看着指针。你不想告诉我你想要我做什么。我当时非常恐慌，因为我需要成为你所需要的人，而你却什么都不需要。然后我感觉到一种断裂，我变得与你分开了，我意识到我是我自己的个体。我可以做我想做的事。然后我又感觉到另一种断裂。我变得与世界上所有人都分开了，我成为了我自己的个体。我意识到我能够只做我想做的事。我说，那太棒了。我很欣赏这种洞察力。那真的很美。但我没有……他们感觉到了一些东西，你知道，就像尤金·根德林（Eugene Gendlin）所说的“感受到的意义”（felt sense），或者神经科学家所说的“内感受”。
It was a truth that I couldn't have explained to them, that they would have resisted because they couldn't see it. The game prevented that. And that's why, especially Cluster B, personality disorders are so stigmatized. And so easily judged is because everybody likes to get on knowledge fight and listen to Alex Jones and be like, can you believe it? Like they just show the evidence to him. And he says, oh, that's not real.
这是一个我无法向他们解释的真理，他们会抗拒，因为他们看不见。这种游戏阻止了这一点。这就是为什么 B 组人格障碍尤其受到污名化，并且很容易被评判的原因，因为每个人都喜欢在“知识之战”（Knowledge Fight）节目上听亚历克斯·琼斯（Alex Jones）的节目，然后说：你能相信吗？就像他们只是向他展示证据。而他说，哦，那不是真的。
And then they say, well, yeah, it is real. And he said, oh, well, it was made up by somebody else, even though it is real. And they say, well, here's proof that it wasn't made up. And then he says, oh, well, you know, and on and on and on. Like it's all deflection. And people just get so angry that this person can't see it. But that's kind of what therapists feel all the time. Because when you come into the room, most intuitive therapists kind of know what's going on,
然后他们说，好吧，它是真的。他说，哦，那是别人编造的，尽管它是真的。他们说，好吧，这是它不是编造的证据。然后他说，哦，好吧，你知道，如此循环往复。这完全是偏转。人们只是对这个人看不见这一点感到非常愤怒。但这正是治疗师一直以来的感受。因为当你走进房间时，大多数直觉敏锐的治疗师都知道发生了什么，
but they can't quite tell you yet because you're not ready to hear it on a felt emotional level. And it's the job of the therapy modality or the therapist to lead you into the place where you can tell yourself. Because you're the only one that can. can. And that's how you treat somebody with an attachment disorder that, you know, the DSM 4 or 5 would call a personality disorder is when there's somebody who's playing a game all the time that they don't even know it's a secret even from themselves, where they're in competition or in anger and aggression or in desperate need of other people's emotional participation in their inner world because they feel completely incapable of regulating that inner world themselves.
但他们还不能完全告诉你，因为你还没有准备好在情感层面去听。治疗方式或治疗师的工作就是引导你到达那个你可以告诉自己的地方。因为你是唯一能做到这一点的人。这就是你如何治疗一个患有依恋障碍的人，你知道，DSM-4 或 5 会称之为“人格障碍”，即当有人一直在玩一个游戏，甚至连他们自己都不知道这是一个秘密时，他们处于竞争、愤怒、攻击中，或者极度需要他人的情感参与到他们的内心世界中，因为他们觉得完全没有能力自己调节那个内心世界。
That is something that happens. You know, what you want to call it if you want to say, it's BPD or whatever. That is how those Cluster B personalities disorders work in my head when I'm doing therapy. And those things are a system. In the last podcast episode, I talked about how we need to understand that these aren't a checklist. Because the problem with BPD is that most people that are diagnosed with it don't actually have it. They're not even close to criteria. It's also used in a very sexist way.
这是会发生的事情。你知道，如果你想称之为 BPD 或其他什么，那没关系。这就是我在做治疗时，脑海中那些 B 组人格障碍是如何运作的。这些东西是一个系统。在上一期播客中，我谈到了我们需要理解这些不是一个检查清单。因为 BPD 的问题在于，大多数被诊断为该病的人实际上并没有患病。他们甚至不符合标准。它也被以一种非常性别歧视的方式使用。
I think in the DSM2, it was passive, a great. progressive personality disorder. And it was almost entirely women because a lot of times, especially when the DSM 2 is out, I mean, not that we've made a ton of progress on, you know, feminism, but like the people who don't have, you know, external power, hierarchical power, systems power will develop a system of passive power. And that at that time was going to be mostly women. And then it got merged into DSM, what, three?
我想在 DSM-2 中，它被称为“被动攻击型人格障碍”。而且几乎全是女性，因为很多时候，特别是在 DSM-2 发布时——并不是说我们在女权主义方面取得了巨大进步——但那些没有外部权力、等级权力、系统权力的人会发展出一套被动权力系统。在那个时候，这主要是女性。然后它被合并到了 DSM-3 中，我想？
I think they got rid of passive aggressive and they made it on borderline. But one of the ways that that system works is that it needs to kind of be felt out. Why is this person doing the behavior? Because like I said, we all do some of those behaviors some of the time, sometimes for good reason and sometimes with understandable circumstances that led up to them. And if you go to the ER and you are a woman and you have good reason to be in crisis because you're being abused. because you're being attacked because bad things have happened because you're at the worst point in your life, whatever led you to go to the ER with a psych diagnosis. You'll be clocked with a BPD diagnosis a ton of the time. I see that so much on these ER discharges. And that doctor,
我想他们取消了被动攻击型，把它变成了边缘型。但那个系统运作的方式之一是，它需要被感受出来。为什么这个人会有这种行为？因为正如我所说，我们所有人有时都会表现出这些行为，有时是有充分理由的，有时是因为导致这些行为的可理解的情况。如果你去急诊室，你是一名女性，你有充分的理由陷入危机，因为你受到了虐待，因为你受到了攻击，因为发生了糟糕的事情，因为你处于人生中最糟糕的时刻，无论是什么导致你带着心理诊断去急诊室。你会被贴上 BPD 的诊断标签，这种情况非常多。我在这些急诊室出院记录中经常看到这种情况。而那位医生，
you may be more emotionally intelligent than the person who diagnosed you with that, the resident who's working the psych ER because they didn't have time to figure out what's going on. They just knew that you were suicidal or you're a crisis, it's an easy diagnosis. They put it on the sheet. It's not accurate. You know, you may be had good reason to do that. I see people that are nowhere close to criteria for BPD that have been diagnosed with it multiple times because they encountered medical situation in crisis. And I just want to say here too, like if you have a diagnosis, there's not like one system that shows that to everybody. It's in the hospital. You know, it's like a lot of people are afraid this like goes into some national registry and they track it or
你可能比那个给你诊断的医生——那个在心理急诊室工作的住院医生——更有情感智慧，因为他们没有时间去弄清楚发生了什么。他们只知道你有自杀倾向或者你处于危机中，这是一个简单的诊断。他们把它写在纸上。这不准确。你知道，你可能有充分的理由那样做。我看到很多人根本不符合 BPD 的标准，却因为在危机中遇到医疗状况而被多次诊断为该病。我也想在这里说，如果你有一个诊断，并没有一个系统向所有人展示它。它在医院里。你知道，很多人担心这会进入某种国家登记系统，他们会追踪它，或者……
whatever. Like there's no way for me to know unless you give me permission to ask for your medical records because you want me to and then another doctor finally fulfills the request and sends them over. It's not like a lot of people are afraid of the diagnosis because they're afraid that once they get it, it can't change or something. You can go to 10 psychiatrists and you can get 10 diagnoses. You just can. If these systems worked consistently, then I think maybe people would be more willing to consider them a hard science. But they don't. You know, there's all these catch 22s in health care that are kind of absurd. I mean one of the things that drove me nuts. You can say this now because I don't ever have to work at the hospital again, I hope.
无论如何。除非你给我许可让我索取你的医疗记录，因为你希望我这样做，然后另一位医生最终完成了请求并把它们发过来，否则我没有办法知道。并不是像很多人担心的那样，他们害怕这个诊断，因为他们担心一旦得到它，就无法改变或什么的。你可以去看 10 个精神科医生，你可以得到 10 个诊断。你真的可以。如果这些系统运作一致，那么我想也许人们会更愿意认为它们是一门硬科学。但它们不是。你知道，医疗保健中存在所有这些荒谬的“第 22 条军规”（Catch-22）。我是说，有一件事让我抓狂。你现在可以说了，因为我希望我再也不用在医院工作了。
But like, who knows at the hospital? They're always like, I mean, some people would have 30 diagnoses in the system and would be like, they'd be like, you have to delete all these. Well, why? Because they're wrong. They're not, they're not right. Well, a doctor diagnosed him with it. Why are they wrong? Oh, they know, they just come and they pick up these diagnoses in the ER were in the psych, but we know the person and they don't have that. So, just delete all these from the treatment plan. Okay, well, I'll delete them from the treatment plan, but they're imported like every single time. So can we just delete them from the system so that it doesn't do that because you're always mad when
但是，谁知道医院里发生了什么？他们总是说，我是说，有些人系统里有 30 个诊断，他们会说，你必须删除所有这些。好吧，为什么？因为它们是错的。它们不正确。好吧，医生诊断了它。为什么它们是错的？哦，他们知道，他们只是在急诊室或心理科捡到了这些诊断，但我们了解这个人，他们没有那个病。所以，只要从治疗计划中删除所有这些。好吧，我会从治疗计划中删除它们，但它们每次都会被导入。所以我们能不能直接从系统中删除它们，这样它就不会那样做了，因为你总是很生气，当……
somebody forgets to delete them? No, no, you're a social worker. You can't delete a doctor's diagnosis, but it's 13 years old and you just told me it's wrong. No, but you're a social worker, you can't delete a doctor's diagnosis. Okay, fine. Can a doctor change the diagnosis? Oh, yeah, a doctor could. Okay, can we get a doctor to do that?
有人忘记删除它们时？不，不，你是一名社会工作者。你不能删除医生的诊断，但它已经 13 年了，你刚才告诉我它是错的。不，但你是一名社会工作者，你不能删除医生的诊断。好吧，好吧。医生可以更改诊断吗？哦，是的，医生可以。好吧，我们能找个医生做这件事吗？
No, doctors don't change other doctor's diagnoses. I mean, I heard that so many times. And what? It's wrong. Get it out of the computer. You know, these catch 22s riddle health care and they're absurd. You know, I talked about the Stardee scandal last time. And I'm not going to go over that one again, but like look up.
不，医生不会更改其他医生的诊断。我是说，我听过很多次了。什么？它是错的。把它从电脑里删掉。你知道，这些“第 22 条军规”困扰着医疗保健，而且它们很荒谬。你知道，我上次谈到了 Stardee 丑闻。我不会再讲一遍了，但去查查。
You know, the body of science that says the system should work this way and how that body of science actually work so that you can have an informed critique and also protect yourself while getting what you need out of it because we still have to participate in psychological. health care we need to know these things um you know a lot of borderline it's an interesting diagnosis because it happened at this time where they were trying to put things into categories and the people who came up with them they were like well you know there's these people that are psychotic like they see ghosts and spirits and hear voices and they you know think that they're talking to aliens or whatever and that's
你知道，科学界认为系统应该这样运作，以及科学界实际上是如何运作的，这样你就可以有一个知情的批评，同时在从中获得你所需的东西时保护自己，因为我们仍然必须参与心理健康护理，我们需要知道这些事情。嗯，你知道，很多边缘型人格障碍是一个有趣的诊断，因为它发生在他们试图将事物分类的时候，而提出这些分类的人，他们就像是，好吧，你知道，有些人是精神病患者，比如他们看到鬼魂和灵魂，听到声音，他们认为自己在和外星人说话，或者其他什么，那……
not real and then there's these people that are neurotic and they just have fixations anxiety fits um anger you know different things uh but they still are oriented in reality in a way the psychotic people aren't but these things that they were trying to define that would later be called you know a borderline group in 1938 i think stern was the guy that that one i think it was adolf stern don't quote me um you know he was like these patients are in this borderline group because they're relatively oriented to reality. Like they're in the same reality as us more so than the reality that the person was schizophrenia is in. But they sometimes aren't. So what do we do with them if they're not psychotic and they're not neurotic? Because I'm doing
不是真的。然后有这些人是神经症患者，他们只是有固着、焦虑发作、愤怒，你知道，不同的事情，但他们仍然以一种精神病患者不具备的方式定位在现实中。但这些他们试图定义的东西，后来被称为边缘型群体，我想是在 1938 年，斯特恩（Stern）是那个人，我想是阿道夫·斯特恩（Adolf Stern），别引用我的话，你知道，他说这些病人属于这个边缘群体，因为他们相对定位在现实中。就像他们和我们处于同一个现实中，比精神分裂症患者所处的现实更接近。但他们有时并不处于现实中。所以如果他们既不是精神病患者也不是神经症患者，我们该拿他们怎么办？因为我正在做……
therapy with this person. And while I'm doing therapy with them, they're telling me about all this stuff and it's real. And then all of a sudden we get into emotional territory and then I'm attacking them. They just they won't answer the question because I lunged across the room and I said I leaned forward slightly but I don't know no no you did you did this and you're just something you dad and I will now have a boundary against you or you know whatever and then you're like well and then other times well four other people were there and we're doing family therapy and they all said that this person just said this kind of slight criticism of you and you're saying that they yelled at you and attacked you and well you're they're all in a conspiracy against me but I they don't have a psychotic paranoia like paranoid schizophrenia. but only around these things, they lose all touch with reality. Reality becomes plastic when you have an emotional need, an emotional narrative that is so deep and so true to you, that when it is challenged, all of a sudden, your mind confabulates ways that the narrative that is more important than any other system in the brain has to be real.
和这个人做治疗。当我在做治疗时，他们告诉我所有这些事情，而且它是真实的。然后突然我们进入了情感领域，然后我在攻击他们。他们只是……他们不会回答这个问题，因为我猛地冲过房间，我说我稍微向前倾了一下，但我不知道，不，不，你做了，你做了这个，你做了那个，我现在要对你设防，或者你知道，无论什么。然后你会说，好吧，然后其他时候，有四个人在场，我们正在做家庭治疗，他们都说这个人只是对你说了这种轻微的批评，而你说他们对你大喊大叫并攻击你，好吧，他们都在密谋反对我，但我……他们没有精神病性的偏执，不像偏执型精神分裂症。但只有在这些事情上，他们失去了与现实的所有联系。当你有一种情感需求、一种对你来说如此深刻且真实的叙事时，现实就会变得可塑，当它受到挑战时，突然间，你的大脑会编造出比大脑中任何其他系统都更重要的叙事，它必须是真实的。
And that's what a personality disorder is doing, but it's only around certain things. It's not all the time. You can still have a good day. You can still go into a Walmart and get a coffee. well you know like coffee at Walmart but uh whatever you can go to a restaurant and do different things and your beliefs are not being challenged these issues are not coming up and then all of a sudden maybe somebody comes to me and they say something and then then it comes up but it wasn't traditional psychosis because it wasn't endogenous to the brain it was part of a story they were telling and then
这就是人格障碍在做的事情，但它只围绕某些事情。它不是一直都在发生。你仍然可以度过美好的一天。你仍然可以去沃尔玛买杯咖啡。好吧，你知道，像沃尔玛的咖啡，但无论如何，你可以去餐馆做不同的事情，你的信念没有受到挑战，这些问题没有出现，然后突然间，也许有人来找我，他们说了些什么，然后它就出现了。但这不是传统的精神病，因为它不是大脑内源性的，它是他们正在讲述的故事的一部分，然后……
you have like auto kernberg who comes in and plays with the idea and he says you know they can reality tests most of the time but only have primitive, this is their language, not mine, defenses like splitting and exaggerated affect, you know. And when the modern diagnostic system came about in 1980, when the DSM3 came out, you know, borderline personality disorder became this formal diagnosis that it focused less on psychosis and more an emotional instability and identity disturbance and fear of abandonment, impulsivity, and the border concept. was never renamed, it's still there.
你有像奥托·克恩伯格（Otto Kernberg）这样的人，他介入并玩弄这个想法，他说，你知道，他们大多数时候可以进行现实测试，但只有原始的——这是他们的语言，不是我的——防御机制，比如分裂和夸张的情感，你知道。当现代诊断系统在 1980 年出现，当 DSM-3 发布时，你知道，边缘型人格障碍成为了这种正式的诊断，它不再关注精神病，而是更多地关注情绪不稳定、身份障碍、被遗弃的恐惧、冲动性，而“边缘”这个概念从未被重命名，它仍然在那里。
And in contemporary trauma-informed models, most people would say it's an attachment disorder that comes from like really early childhood wounds, you know, one or many, where somebody is playing this game of trying to be safe all the time, but they don't know that the world actually is safe now. And unlike someone with PTSD that's having flashbacks or physical emotionally experiencing,
在当代创伤知情模型中，大多数人会说这是一种依恋障碍，源于非常早期的童年创伤，你知道，一个或多个，有人一直在玩这种试图一直保持安全的游戏，但他们不知道世界现在实际上是安全的。与患有 PTSD 且有闪回或身体情感体验的人不同，
they're having, I mean, you can have both. You can have BPD and PTSD. Most people do, and those disorders, one of the reasons I don't like them is that they probably should be three or four, you know, overlapping, you know, whatever. But that idea that this person is on the border of sanity, but certain things knock them off the edge of tolerable emotional experience out of the window of tolerance and then things become not real for them.
他们有……我是说，你可以两者兼有。你可以同时患有 BPD 和 PTSD。大多数人都有，而这些障碍，我不喜欢它们的原因之一是它们可能应该是三四个，你知道，重叠的，你知道，无论什么。但那种认为这个人处于理智边缘的想法，但某些事情把他们撞出了可忍受的情感体验的边缘，超出了容忍窗口，然后事情对他们来说就变得不真实了。
And one of the things these early guys noticed is like, these patients don't respond to psychoanalysis. You can give them so much insight. You can give them so much relationship. You can give them so much love. And all that happens is that they need more and more and more, which is why a lot of people say that BPD, you sense it in their room as somebody having a black hole.
这些早期的人注意到的一件事是，这些病人对精神分析没有反应。你可以给他们那么多的洞察力。你可以给他们那么多的关系。你可以给他们那么多的爱。而发生的一切只是他们需要更多、更多、更多，这就是为什么很多人说 BPD，你在房间里感觉到它就像有人有一个黑洞。
Also, I notice that a lot of borderline patients around the chest, they have a feeling of a black hole sucking or a burning heat. There is kind of a void that shows up in semantic work with that. And a lot of that, those early clinicians were sort of trying to figure out what it was. And that's the history of. of it that we forget because let's remember how many times the DSM changed its entire idea because the DSM kind of changed. I have an article about like how America changes psychology and psychiatry to fit its own
此外，我注意到很多边缘型患者在胸部周围，有一种黑洞在吸吮或灼热的感觉。在语义工作中确实会出现一种虚空。而很多早期临床医生都在试图弄清楚它是什么。这就是我们忘记的历史，因为让我们记住 DSM 改变了多少次它的整个想法，因为 DSM 改变了。我有一篇文章关于美国如何改变心理学和精神病学以适应其自身的……
identity of what itself, what the how we define self, what self it is like in any era. And the DSM rebranded essentially three times. It's interesting to me that in the first DSM, they said this will never be used for insurance billing for classification. only for research and medical treatment, and that lasted about two weeks. But the DSM, you know, it rebranded three times, basically. So at first it's looking at reactions. It's looking at these systematic, dynamic systems that are out of balance.
身份，关于它自己，我们如何定义自我，它是什么样的自我，在任何时代。DSM 本质上重塑了三次品牌。对我来说有趣的是，在第一版 DSM 中，他们说这永远不会用于保险计费分类，只用于研究和医疗，这持续了大约两周。但 DSM，你知道，它重塑了三次品牌，基本上。所以起初它是在看反应。它是在看这些失去平衡的系统性、动态系统。
And then you get, you know, the empty, dull thud experiments that Rosenhand did. A lot of the DSM3 was a response to that, where, you know, he said, We never solved this problem, by the way, too. Somebody should do the Rosenen experiment again. You'd probably go to jail and lose your license at this point. You wouldn't be able to teach at Harvard. But what Rosanan did was he told all of his graduate psych students, we're going to go get committed.
然后你得到，你知道，罗森汉（Rosenhan）做的“空洞、沉闷、砰”（empty, dull thud）实验。DSM-3 的很大一部分是对那个实验的回应，在那里，你知道，他说，顺便说一句，我们从未解决这个问题。有人应该再做一次罗森汉实验。你现在可能会坐牢并失去执照。你将无法在哈佛任教。但罗森汉所做的是，他告诉他所有的研究生心理学学生，我们要去被收容。
We're going to do an experiment. We're going to go in and we're going to say, we heard a voice say empty dull thought. We hear a voice that says empty dull thought. And everyone says the psychiatrist is this genius who's able to, you know, just detect what's going on in the person. And we're going to prove that that's not right. And they went in and they did it and all these Harvard graduate clinical psych students get committed.
我们要做一个实验。我们要进去，我们要说，我们听到一个声音说“空洞、沉闷、砰”。我们听到一个声音说“空洞、沉闷、砰”。每个人都说精神科医生是天才，能够，你知道，只是检测出那个人身上发生了什么。我们要证明那是不对的。他们进去了，他们做了，所有这些哈佛临床心理学研究生都被收容了。
And then they can't get out. And then eventually they get out and they publish a paper and they say, this is bullshit. You don't know what people have. We just went in and said this. And then you also have people like R.D. Lang, who are incredibly critical and of organized psychiatry. And they lead the anti-psychiatry movement in the 60s and the 70s.
然后他们出不来了。然后最终他们出来了，他们发表了一篇论文，他们说，这简直是胡扯。你们根本不知道人们有什么病。我们只是进去说了这个。然后你也有像 R.D. 莱恩（R.D. Laing）这样的人，他们对有组织的精神病学极其批评。他们在 60 年代和 70 年代领导了反精神病学运动。
And so the GSM says, okay, fine, we're going to take away all of that subjective intuition to detect systems and things out of balance and whatever. And the psychotius is no longer allowed to trust their autonomy. They're no longer to trust subjective intuition. And a lot of psychiatry at this time was abusive. There should be checks on that. But, you know, the history of this profession is corrections and way over corrections in the wrong direction, you know, because we can't identify like what needs to change.
所以 DSM 说，好吧，好吧，我们要拿走所有那些主观直觉来检测系统和失去平衡的事物等等。精神科医生不再被允许信任他们的自主权。他们不再被允许信任主观直觉。当时很多精神病学是虐待性的。应该对此进行检查。但是，你知道，这个职业的历史是修正和向错误方向的过度修正，你知道，因为我们无法识别什么需要改变。
We just change everything. and we could but we don't and so after that they said they'll just be checklist they'll be checklist for everything and if you check these boxes you have this diagnosis
我们只是改变了一切。我们可以，但我们没有。所以在那之后，他们说它们只是检查清单，它们将是所有东西的检查清单，如果你勾选了这些框，你就有这个诊断。
now it's scientific now it's based on numbers now it's based on order and because it's based on that so you get this checklist model that keeps the borderline name even though it's no longer about system so it doesn't quite make sense because what is it on a border between the neurosis
现在它是科学的，现在它是基于数字的，现在它是基于秩序的，因为它基于那个，所以你得到了这个检查清单模型，它保留了边缘型的名字，即使它不再是关于系统，所以它不太有意义，因为它处于神经症和……
and psychosis things, not how they want to conceive of it anymore. And now, you know, the DSM-4, they acted like they were going to get further with the human genome project and all these different research studies. And they were going to understand the brain-mind problem where consciousness really was what it was doing. We'll find more biological variables that are the, because they keep trying to turn psychiatry into the germ theory. Like, we have to find a thing that causes these. We can't look at the environment at all.
精神病事物之间的边缘，不是他们现在想要构想它的方式。现在，你知道，DSM-4，他们表现得好像他们要通过人类基因组计划和所有这些不同的研究进一步发展。他们要理解大脑-心灵问题，意识到底在做什么。我们会找到更多生物学变量，因为他们一直试图把精神病学变成细菌理论。就像，我们必须找到导致这些疾病的东西。我们根本不能看环境。
Like, it's not any of those things. We don't want to talk about what your mom did. We don't want to talk about, you know, trauma. We don't want to talk about racism. We don't want to talk about systemic problems, access to health care. We just want to find the biological variable. That's the reason why you are defective. But suffering is a part of making meaning.
就像，它不是那些东西中的任何一个。我们不想谈论你妈妈做了什么。我们不想谈论，你知道，创伤。我们不想谈论种族主义。我们不想谈论系统性问题，医疗保健的可及性。我们只想找到生物学变量。这就是你是有缺陷的原因。但痛苦是创造意义的一部分。
It's part of us. We can't, you know, that project didn't really work. And so the DSM4 is kind of rushed out and highly criticized and not well. And it starts with the DSM4 TR and then furthered by the five to move to this spectrum model. They're like, okay, well, it's a diagnosis. But then the diagnoses are like all wrong and don't work. work. So we're going to put it on a spectrum where you have a little bit or a lot of it, which also doesn't really work. You know, they did that with autism too. And they wanted to,
它是我们的一部分。我们不能，你知道，那个项目并没有真正奏效。所以 DSM-4 有点仓促推出，受到高度批评，效果不好。它从 DSM-4 TR 开始，然后由第五版进一步推动转向这个谱系模型。他们就像，好吧，好吧，这是一个诊断。但然后诊断就像全错了，不起作用。所以我们要把它放在一个谱系上，你有少许或很多它，这也不太起作用。你知道，他们对自闭症也做了同样的事情。他们想要……
you know, not change that underlying assumption that suffering is a biological defect. They didn't want to change that it could be this meaningful response to life that could be engaged with because that's too messy. And so it makes this persistence of of BPD this kind of deeply strange diagnosis that's like a fossil from the first era that is prevalent enough that it sticks around but that all the assumptions about it and how to treat it and even its name don't make any sense in the three errors and eras in which it has lived and so it now sits kind of awkwardly in the spectrum model but we can't really link it to trauma because PTSD is different but like you had to have the trauma to get the B that hasn't I mean read the DSM 5 entries I
你知道，不改变那种认为痛苦是生物学缺陷的潜在假设。他们不想改变它可能是一种可以参与的、对生活有意义的反应，因为那太混乱了。所以它使得 BPD 的这种持续存在成为一种极其奇怪的诊断，就像第一时代的化石，它足够普遍以至于它留了下来，但关于它的所有假设以及如何治疗它，甚至它的名字，在它所经历的三个时代中都没有任何意义，所以它现在在谱系模型中坐得有点尴尬，但我们不能真正把它与创伤联系起来，因为 PTSD 是不同的，但就像你必须有创伤才能得到 B，那并没有……我是说，读读 DSM-5 的条目，我……
on these things, they don't explain that relationship well because they still need it to be a diagnosis that's a code for insurance and not a system of trauma when? You know, 40 years ago and now you have a personality disorder, you know, what is the, so, you know, the result is this diagnosis that pathologizes a person's survival mechanism that was useful at one time or they wouldn't have it. You know, we tend to not do things for no reason as humans. It doesn't make sense in the time that they're doing it now in the present, but it's this permanent internal defense that the person forgot why it existed.
关于这些事情，它们没有很好地解释那种关系，因为它们仍然需要它成为一个保险代码的诊断，而不是一个创伤系统。你知道，40 年前，现在你有人格障碍，你知道，什么是……所以，你知道，结果是这个诊断，它病理化了一个人的生存机制，这种机制在某个时候是有用的，否则他们就不会有它。你知道，作为人类，我们倾向于不做无缘无故的事情。它在他们现在所处的当下时间里没有意义，但它是这种永久的内部防御，那个人忘记了它为什么存在。
But it's not a disease that comes from a germ. So you're still trying to blame the patient's biology for their adaptation to this chaotic environment, which is one of the reasons why I don't really like the diagnosis is it doesn't really spell that out. That all has to be inferred clinically. You know, you get it at a training. But it's not part of the actual conceptualization. that's supposed to be undergardeing the profession. And so, you know, that term comes from 20th century psychology,
但它不是一种来自细菌的疾病。所以你仍然试图把病人的生物学归咎于他们对这个混乱环境的适应，这就是为什么我不太喜欢这个诊断的原因之一，它没有真正说明这一点。所有这些都必须在临床上推断出来。你知道，你在培训中得到它。但它不是应该支撑这个职业的实际概念化的一部分。所以，你知道，那个术语来自 20 世纪心理学，
and those clinicians were noticing these patients that didn't fit into the categories at the time, and they tried to make them fit into the categories for the next cycle, and the next one, and it hasn't really fit, because on one side of the border was neurotic disorders, and the other side of the border was psychosis. And the borderline people were, they were saying basically they're sort of in the middle of psychosis
那些临床医生注意到这些病人不符合当时的类别，他们试图让他们适应下一个周期的类别，以及下一个，它并没有真正适应，因为在边界的一边是神经症障碍，边界的另一边是精神病。而边缘型的人，他们基本上是在说他们有时处于精神病……
some of the time, because reality can become plastic them. But remember what I said about social work school, though, right? Like, we all do some of these things, some of the time. And we do them when we're at more stress. So if I'm in an environment where I lose my job, I have no money, and then I'm out of my window of tolerance all the time, and I start acting worse,
中间，因为现实对他们来说可以变得可塑。但记住我关于社会工作学校所说的，对吧？就像，我们所有人有时都会做这些事情中的一些。当我们压力更大时，我们会做这些事情。所以如果我处于一个我失去工作、没有钱的环境中，然后我一直处于我的容忍窗口之外，我开始表现得更糟，
Do I have BPD all of a sudden? I said I do that stuff to my wife some of the time. My life gets worse. Maybe I do it more. If I'm rich enough that I can insulate myself from all the consequences of doing it, then do I not have it? Does the person who is poorer have more BPD because they're in an environment that is activating the symptom more of the time? I mean, I don't know. You guys tell me because it's not in the DSM.
我突然患有 BPD 了吗？我说我有时会对我的妻子做那些事。我的生活变得更糟。也许我做得更多。如果我足够富有，我可以让自己免受做这件事的所有后果，那么我没有它吗？那个更穷的人是否有更多的 BPD，因为他们处于一个一直激活症状的环境中？我是说，我不知道。你们告诉我，因为它不在 DSM 中。
That is still roughly a checklist, even if they tried to make. it, you know, spectrum differential diagnosis, it doesn't really explain how to handle those things well at the conceptualization phase. And the DSM is supposed to be how we conceptualize things. So I don't know. You tell me how to do with it. I've asked this question in a lot of conferences. And people are like, yeah, yeah, well, the DSM says that. And then you just go do your own thing. Okay, why is it there? You don't have to take my word for it. I'm not the first person to make this argument or the best person. I mean, you know, Thomas Zazz is mates the myth. You know, in the 60s argument and says, like, you know, disease is a physical thing in the body.
那仍然大致是一个检查清单，即使他们试图使它……你知道，谱系鉴别诊断，它并没有真正解释在概念化阶段如何很好地处理这些事情。而 DSM 应该是我们如何概念化事物的方式。所以我不知道。你告诉我怎么处理它。我在很多会议上问过这个问题。人们就像，是的，是的，好吧，DSM 是那样说的。然后你就去做你自己的事。好吧，它为什么在那里？你不必相信我的话。我不是第一个提出这个论点的人，也不是最好的人。我是说，你知道，托马斯·萨兹（Thomas Szasz）提出了“神话”论点。你知道，在 60 年代的论点，他说，你知道，疾病是身体里的一种物理事物。
So saying mental illness is stupid because mental illness is just a metaphor for problems in living. And we should just view them as that, not, you know, they don't need to be diseases at all. You have, you know, Thomas Encel is the biology argument where he's like, you know, the DSM is at best, it's just a dictionary. It's a weakness because it has no validity. You know, other medicine has a blood test that tells you if you have a disease. this one is just this stuff that changes all the time. Even patients that we're screening regularly are getting different disorders. So like I don't really think it works.
所以说精神疾病是愚蠢的，因为精神疾病只是生活问题的隐喻。我们应该把它们视为那样，而不是，你知道，它们根本不需要是疾病。你有，你知道，托马斯·因塞尔（Thomas Insel）的生物学论点，他就像，你知道，DSM 充其量只是字典。它是一个弱点，因为它没有有效性。你知道，其他医学有血液测试来告诉你是否有疾病。这个只是这些一直都在变的东西。即使是我们定期筛查的病人也得到了不同的障碍。所以，我不认为它有效。
We're going to move our funding away from it. You know, Alan Francis said, you know, he argued, I think saving normal was his book. But he said, you know, the DSM5 process was sloppy and it led to this diagnostic inflation because you're putting people on the spectrum. And now all of a sudden you're putting more people on it because you've broadened by the definition. by the definition of spectrum, it's not one destination. It's now this range. You've broadened it.
我们要把我们的资金从它身上移开。你知道，艾伦·弗朗西斯（Allen Frances）说，你知道，他争辩说，我想《拯救正常》（Saving Normal）是他的书。但他说了，你知道，DSM-5 的过程很草率，它导致了这种诊断膨胀，因为你把人们放在谱系上。现在突然间你把更多的人放在上面，因为你通过定义拓宽了它。通过谱系的定义，它不是一个目的地。它现在是这个范围。你拓宽了它。
Now everybody is like meeting these categories, which I think that's kind of true. I mean, I have a lot of people that write me and try and get me to say that I have autism or that I have ADHD. And I definitely have, you know, some traits that are ADHD and autistic like.
现在每个人都好像符合这些类别，我认为这有点真实。我是说，我有很多人写信给我，试图让我说我有自闭症或者我有 ADHD。我确实有，你知道，一些 ADHD 和自闭症样的特征。
But I, and I'm not saying one way or the other. Mainly I just kind of don't care because those things are things that I use in life to be successful and they're not detracting from anything. I'm not having problems getting things done that I want to do. And so I don't really need treatment for it, but they're like, but you still have to identify with that and live it to be a mental illness informed clinician or not informed, what do they call it? I don't know. You're representing the community or something. And my thing is that like if you want to say that I have autism, I'm not saying I don't,
但我，我不是说一种方式或另一种方式。主要是因为我不太在乎，因为那些东西是我在生活中用来取得成功的东西，它们没有减损任何东西。我没有在完成我想做的事情方面遇到问题。所以我真的不需要治疗它，但他们就像，但你仍然必须认同它并活出它，才能成为一个心理健康知情的临床医生，或者不知情，他们叫什么？我不知道。你代表社区什么的。而我的观点是，如果你想说我有自闭症，我不是说我没有，
then you're saying that everybody who is a little bit intuitive, everybody who can kind of understand the way these systems work in a way that they're unimpressed with like hierarchies and they're able to read behavior and they're able to be, you know, deeply recognized patterns and synthesize information and they maybe have like a wandering focus of interest that's very specific.
那么你是在说，每一个有点直觉的人，每一个能理解这些系统运作方式的人，以一种他们对等级制度不以为然的方式，他们能够阅读行为，他们能够，你知道，深刻地识别模式并综合信息，他们可能有一个非常具体的游离的兴趣焦点。
I'm not saying that is or is an autism that I am I'm not autistic, but what I'm saying is that if you want to make that the diagnosis, how many people is that in the country, right? Like these spectrums, you know, had these huge ranges, which is what Francis is pointing out. You have Kerry Greenberg. You know, and he says that the DSM is basically a work of fiction. It's this noble lie that insurances making clinicians tell, even though a lot of them when they pull them anonymously, they don't want to.
我不是说那是或不是自闭症，我不是自闭症患者，但我想说的是，如果你想把它作为诊断，全国有多少人是这样？对吧？就像这些谱系，你知道，有这些巨大的范围，这就是弗朗西斯指出的。你有凯里·格林伯格（Kerry Greenberg）。你知道，他说 DSM 基本上是一部虚构作品。它是保险公司让临床医生讲述的高尚谎言，尽管当他们匿名调查时，很多人并不想这样做。
And these are just voted into existence by a group of psychiatrists that says, hey, this exists this year. I got in, I blocked, I think, by this person in Australia or somewhere, psychiatrist. And she was talking about how it was so important to have a diagnosis and we didn't have one, you couldn't get better, whatever. And I was just like, okay, thought experiment. Why? And she was like, because that's what lets you love yourself and accept all the parts of
而这些只是由一群精神科医生投票产生的，他们说，嘿，今年这个存在。我被这个人，我想是澳大利亚或某个地方的精神科医生，屏蔽了。她在谈论拥有一个诊断是多么重要，如果我们没有一个，你就无法好转，无论什么。我只是，好吧，思想实验。为什么？她说，因为那是让你爱自己并接受所有部分的东西。
yourself and understand how you think and then heal. I was like, okay, no, I think loving yourself, accepting yourself and understanding the parts of yourself and then healing and. raising your window of tolerance are the thing that matters not the code like if i did that for reactive attachment disorder as an adult in the dsm 2 and got learned how to do all those things and then all of a sudden the dsm 3 said never mind anyone over 14 can't have reactive attachment disorder does that mean what that was a useful diagnosis i wish i kept that one around like then why um does that i mean that i don't have those three things all of a sudden that i have to like be like
了解你自己，明白你的思维方式，然后进行疗愈。我当时想，不，我认为爱自己、接纳自己、理解自己的各个部分，然后进行疗愈并提高你的容纳之窗，这才是最重要的，而不是那些诊断代码。如果我作为一个成年人，在DSM-2（精神疾病诊断与统计手册第2版）中被诊断为反应性依恋障碍，并学会了如何处理所有这些问题，然后突然间DSM-3说“算了，任何超过14岁的人都不能有反应性依恋障碍”，那这是否意味着那个曾经有用的诊断失效了？我真希望保留那个诊断。那为什么……我的意思是，难道我突然之间就没有那三个问题了吗？难道我必须表现得像……
oh, I got to go treat another diagnosis. I don't love myself anymore. I don't understand how I think, and I definitely can't accept anything or act effectively. Like, no. Like, that was the point. The diagnosis was arbitrary. She blocked me.
哦，我得去治疗另一个诊断了。我不爱自己了，我不明白自己的思维方式，而且我绝对无法接受任何事情或有效地行动。不，根本不是这样。诊断本身是武断的。她屏蔽了我。
She didn't response. I don't know. And I said it nice. I said it like that. But the French philosopher who, you know, Foucault, like he said, you know, mental illness is not really scientific fact, but it's this cultural tool.
她没有回复。我不知道。我当时说得很委婉，就是那样说的。但是法国哲学家福柯说过，精神疾病并不是真正的科学事实，而是一种文化工具。
And then it's used to silence and control people who don't fit the rational, productive norms. I largely think that I don't lean into those kind of arguments that they get made a lot on kind of fringy podcasts and things. Because I don't think it's that intentional. Like I don't think that the psychiatrists think that they're doing this evil thing and that like hoodwinking everybody. I think there's a system that is an incentive structure. A lot of it has to do with the profit motive.
它被用来压制和控制那些不符合理性、生产力规范的人。我并不完全倾向于这种观点，尽管这些论点在一些边缘播客中经常被提及。因为我不认为这是蓄意的。我不认为精神科医生认为自己在做邪恶的事情，或者在欺骗所有人。我认为这是一个激励结构系统。其中很大一部分与利润动机有关。
And that what that system does is it plays on everybody's blind spots and everyone's insecurity. siloing information and making sure everybody only knows a little bit in academia about one thing. I mean, you can't have 12 PhDs. And then you can't talk about anything that you don't know and you can't see the whole picture. And then you also have to do this financial investment. Then you also have to jump through these hoops to win. And then that filters out a lot of the accountability and the insight for people to see this thing intentionally. I mean, there's so many people who work very, very high up in health care, in mental health care policy.
这个系统所做的是利用每个人的盲点和不安全感。它将信息孤岛化，确保学术界的每个人只了解某一方面的一点点知识。我的意思是，你不可能拥有12个博士学位。你不能谈论你不了解的事情，也无法看到全局。而且你还必须进行这种经济投入。你还必须跳过这些障碍才能获胜。这过滤掉了人们本可以看清真相的洞察力和问责机制。我的意思是，有太多在医疗保健和心理健康政策领域身居高位的人。
making that I've talked to who don't understand how these things work and they're interested for a minute and then they get angry and are like well that can't be true and I'm like it's in a book not a opinion book like a book book like that just has things that happened in it like you can read the history of the profession like you don't have to just start at the point in history in which you were born because we can write things down yeah you have you know David Rosenhan who we already talked about who and he you know said you know being sane and say in places his book and he said that like you know writing in a journal or you know writing things about yourself those were normal and he did those all the time and he was the Harvard professor there I don't know he was Harvard but he was like he was in California
我曾与他们交谈过，他们不了解这些事情是如何运作的。他们起初很感兴趣，然后变得愤怒，说“这不可能是真的”。我说，这写在书里，不是观点书，而是那种记录了真实发生之事的书。你可以阅读这个行业的历史，你不必只从你出生的那个历史节点开始，因为我们可以把事情记录下来。是的，你有大卫·罗森汉（David Rosenhan），我们之前谈到过他，他写了《精神病院里的正常人》（On Being Sane in Insane Places）。他说，写日记或记录关于自己的事情是正常的，他一直都在做这些，他当时是哈佛的教授——我不确定他是不是哈佛的，但他当时在加州。
anyway he was he was big school at the time and he was like that all got pathologized by doctors and they said that I was crazy and they were analyzing these normal things that I do just because I was in a psych ward not in my house You have, you know, Joan Amon-Amene Krife who says, like, that the chemical imbalance theory about low serotonin and all that, that's just this myth. There's no evidence. That's actually really precise. She had a lot of foresight because the stuff that's coming out now, they paid for all of this research about 10 years ago that started coming out about, I don't know, six, five, six years ago. And most of it was kind of confirming that all of the, we had a guess.
总之，他当时在名校，他说这一切都被医生病理化了。他们说我疯了，他们分析我做的这些正常事情，仅仅因为我在精神病院而不是在家里。你有琼·阿蒙-阿门·克莱夫（Joan Amon-Amene Krife），她说化学失衡理论，关于血清素水平低之类的，那只是一个神话。没有证据。这其实非常准确。她很有远见，因为现在出来的东西，他们大约10年前就为所有这些研究付了钱，大约五六年前开始出现。大部分研究都在证实我们之前的猜测。
we thought about why an antidepressants worked and what they were doing in the brain because we don't really understand. And then we tested all of those theories neurobiologically and actually most of them are probably wrong. So we spent a whole lot of money to find out that we know less about why they work. You know, James Davies, he talked about the DSM committees. When they voted on definitions, they often admitted that they had no scientific proof at all. They just sort of thought that was a good way to move the information around.
我们曾思考抗抑郁药为什么有效，以及它们在大脑中做了什么，因为我们并不真正了解。然后我们在神经生物学上测试了所有这些理论，实际上大多数可能都是错的。所以我们花了很多钱，结果发现我们对它们为什么有效了解得更少了。詹姆斯·戴维斯（James Davies）谈到了DSM委员会。当他们投票决定定义时，他们经常承认自己根本没有任何科学证据。他们只是觉得这是一种传播信息的好方法。
They were doing it more like quantum physicists work where they just look for holes in the math and then kind of plug the hole. You know, to draw the line to be normal and disorder was really hard. And even in these rooms where these people are supposed to be doing the most scientific thing, they're just kind of like, oh, this is what I think. And what's scary is a lot of them have no patient contact for many, many years. I mean, a lot of psychiatrists have never been in therapy. And a lot of psychiatrists have never done therapy. I would say most of them. If they've done any, it's like CBT or DBT group or, you know, I volunteered at the student counseling.
他们的做法更像是量子物理学家的工作方式，寻找数学中的漏洞，然后填补漏洞。你知道，划定正常与障碍之间的界限真的很难。即使在这些本应进行最科学工作的房间里，他们也只是说：“哦，这是我的想法。”可怕的是，他们中许多人多年来都没有接触过病人。我的意思是，很多精神科医生从未接受过治疗。很多精神科医生从未进行过治疗。我想说大多数都是这样。如果他们做过，那也只是CBT（认知行为疗法）或DBT（辩证行为疗法）小组，或者，我曾在学生咨询中心做过志愿者。
Center, which there's a gap between working at the student counseling center and what I do. There's also an enormous gap between doing any kind of therapy at all and doing your psych rotation in the ER, you know, which I mean psychiatrists spend more time at psych than that, but you normal doctors, like their encounter with psychology and psychiatry during their, you know, training is that they're in the psych ER or the ER just. doing psychic mission. But, you know, um,
中心，在学生咨询中心工作和我现在做的事情之间是有差距的。在进行任何形式的治疗和在急诊室进行精神科轮转之间也有巨大的差距。我的意思是，精神科医生在精神科花的时间比那多，但普通医生在培训期间接触心理学和精神病学，只是在精神科急诊室或急诊室做精神科收治。但是，嗯……
the R.D. Leng is an interesting one. It won't go on any more about history people and I've talked about him before, but, you know, he talked about just making a profound connection with people and so, because this was so healing and it was our humanity and our story. And even if it was psychotic, if you participate in somebody's story,
R.D.莱恩（R.D. Laing）是一个有趣的人物。我不会再多谈历史人物了，我之前谈过他，但他谈到与人建立深刻的联系，因为这非常有疗愈作用，这是关于我们的人性和我们的故事。即使那是精神病性的，如果你参与了某人的故事，
it starts to ground them and relationally invigorate them. And I think that's true because I've had a lot of dissociative identity disorder patients. It's really overdiagnosed some places. So if you ever meet somebody that's like, oh, I see 30 DID people, unless they're in some kind of like specialized treatment facility. They're over diagnosing. I mean, you maybe get one a year or something. But I've seen a lot in my career. And one of the things that with the ID is that a lot of times they feel so unsafe, they are so activated that they don't remember 40 minutes of a 50 minute session with me. And then they start to remember more because it's not an intellectual logical thing it's that their body is
它就开始让他们脚踏实地，并在关系上激励他们。我认为这是真的，因为我有很多解离性身份障碍（DID）的病人。在某些地方，这被过度诊断了。所以如果你遇到有人说“我看了30个DID病人”，除非他们在某种专门的治疗机构，否则他们是在过度诊断。我的意思是，你一年可能只会遇到一个。但我职业生涯中见过很多。DID患者的情况之一是，他们往往感到非常不安全，处于高度激活状态，以至于他们不记得我50分钟疗程中的40分钟。然后他们开始记得更多，因为这不是一个理性的逻辑问题，而是他们的身体
starting to be more safe they're starting to trust me and they're starting to calm down and it doesn't matter if there's an intellectual memory of it because the safety is the point and the session is still productive you know without me delivering a whole lot of information that they remember because therapy is not really just like raising children or a lot of our communication it's not what we tell our kids to do it's not what we say a lot of it is what we do and embody and are um is is what makes the connection i mean there's those are the old people there's a ton of newer people like alan horwitz and bessel van der Kolk and goormate i think's kind of reductive in some areas but you know there's if you don't want to if you say like your only evidence for why
开始感到更安全，他们开始信任我，开始平静下来。即使没有关于它的理性记忆也无所谓，因为安全感才是重点，疗程依然是有效的。你知道，不需要我提供他们能记住的大量信息，因为治疗不仅仅像抚养孩子或我们的大部分交流。这不是我们告诉孩子做什么，也不是我们说了什么，很多时候是我们做了什么，体现了什么，这才是建立联系的关键。我的意思是，那些是老一辈的人，还有很多新人，比如艾伦·霍维茨（Alan Horwitz）和贝塞尔·范德考克（Bessel van der Kolk）。我认为戈尔马特（Gormate）在某些方面有点还原论，但如果你不想……如果你说你认为深度心理学好的唯一证据是60年代的人（人们经常这么说），你知道，哈林顿（Harrington），2020年，理查德·本托（Richard Bentall）、罗伯特·惠特克（Robert Whitaker）、欧文·胡利（Owen Huli），这些都是非常现代的大人物，他们比我了解得多，而且论证得可能比我在这一个小时里能做的要好得多。但我认为存在一个双重问题，即人们认为边缘型人格障碍（BPD）患者对临床医生有不公平的解释，而且他们无法从治疗中受益，因为他们无法获得洞察力，我认为这不是真的。我认为很多时候，当你只是治疗创伤并建立大量的躯体和关系安全感时，
depth psychology is good is you know people from the 60s which people say a lot you know and Harrington, what, 2020, you know, Richard Bentall, Robert Whitaker, Owen Huli, like, these are big, big modern figures who know a lot more than me and make the argument probably a lot better than I can do, you know, in this hour. But I think that there's this kind of like two-pronged problem where there's this belief that BPD patients have this unfair explanation on that clinician. and they don't benefit from therapy because they can't have insight, which I don't think it's true. I think a lot of times when you just treat trauma and you build a lot of somatic and relational safety,
很多症状就会减轻。这是我与大多数人打交道的经验。我的意思是，有些人你必须设定非常坚定的界限，因为他们会试图在疗程之外联系你或越界。我认为，那些基本上无法在治疗关系中良好运作以在治疗中好转的人，如果你想保留BPD作为一种诊断并区分什么是BPD什么不是，划定那条界限可能并不坏。这可能是个人治疗根本不起作用的界限，因为当事人无法遵守关系规则以从个人治疗中受益。他们需要团体治疗、DBT小组，或者稍微
a lot of those symptoms come down. That's been my experience with most people. I mean, there's some people where you have to have very firm boundaries because they're going to try and contact you out of session or cross lines. And that would be what I think, you know, the people that, you know, basically can't function well enough in the therapeutic relationship. to get better in therapy, that may not be a bad line to draw if you want to keep BPD around as a diagnosis and say, you know, this is BPD and this isn't. It may be the line where individual therapy just doesn't work because the person is not able to obey the rules of a relationship enough to benefit in individual therapy. And they need, you know, group therapy, a DBT group, or something that is a little
结构化一点的环境，在那里他们不被允许做出那些他们还无法做出的关于关系和互动的决定。如果他们违反了治疗关系中可接受行为的规则，以至于治疗根本无法进行，如果你非要保留这个障碍，那就把界限划在那里，而不是像“一个女人去了一次急诊室”那样。我不认为那是站得住脚的或科学的。所以，我的意思是，如果你想把BPD看作一种诊断，就像我刚才说的关于自闭症的事情，如果你想把谱系扩大到包括我，我们到底在包括多少人？
but more structured where they're not allowed to have to make these decisions that they can't make yet about relationships and interaction and appropriately. If they're going to violate the rules of what is acceptable behavior in a therapeutic relationship enough that therapy just won't work, if you're going to keep that disorder around, let's draw the line there, not like a woman went to the ER one time. Like, I don't think that's, I don't think that's, uh, tenable or, or scientific. Um, so, I mean, if you want to look at BPD as a diagnosis, you know, the thing that I was saying about autism, like if you want to make the spectrum big enough to include me, how many people are we
有多少人变成了自闭症患者？我并不是说这是错的或不是发展的方向。我只是说，如果你看看DSM-5的发展方向，它会说更多的人患有谱系障碍，尽管仍然是障碍，如果你继续朝着他们采取的方向创新。看看BPD的症状，你知道，疯狂地努力避免真实或想象中的遗弃。看看美国的对外政策，对例外论的痴迷，以及我们不知何故是所有规则的例外，或者这种
including there? You know, how many people become autistic? And I'm not saying that that's wrong or not the direction to go. I'm just saying that if you look at the way that they're going with the DSM5, it's going to say that a lot more people have a spectrum disorder, albeit still a disorder, if you continue to innovate on it in the direction they're taking it. Look at the symptoms, though, of BPD, you know, frantic efforts to avoid real or imagined abandonment. You know, look at American like foreign policy and obsession with exceptionalism and that we somehow are this exception to all the rules or this
根深蒂固的地缘政治焦虑，我们一直担心必须确保全世界的每个人都在做我们想要他们做的事情。那是BPD吗？并不是每个美国人都相信这一点，但足够多的人参与了这些事情。你知道，标准中关于不稳定和强烈人际关系模式的这一条，你不能与任何人平等相处，你要么高高在上，他们很棒，要么你处于他们之下，他们很糟糕——分裂。我的意思是政治极化，我甚至不知道我是否需要谈论那个。你知道，把人理想化为救世主，然后说“哦，实际上他们很糟糕”，并使用某种缩写来
deep-seated geopolitical anxiety that we have all the time that we have to make sure that everyone in the entire world is doing exactly what we want is that BPD not everybody in America believes that but enough people participate in those things you know criteria to this pattern of unstable and intense interpersonal relationships you can't have any relationship with someone as an equal you're either above them and they're wonderful or you're below them and they're terrible splitting i mean the political polarization you know i don't even know if i need to say anything about that one you know idealizing people as mezzanic saviors and then saying oh actually they're terrible um and using some acronym to
否定他们。在政治领域有多少人——不是说政客，我是说他们也是——如果看看他们说他们想要和相信的东西，他们真的保持一致吗？第三，身份认同障碍，这种明显且持续的不稳定自我形象或自我感模式。美国和大多数美国人有稳定的自我形象吗？你知道，在至少两个潜在的自我伤害领域存在冲动。我们的系统正在支出我们的国家药物滥用，我们的饮食健康，那些我们认为是一个国家显而易见的事情。我们是否在做任何冲动或潜在自我伤害的事情？你能想到任何例子吗？反复的自杀行为、姿态或威胁，或自残行为？我的意思是，我不知道，
write them off how many people in politics not like politicians i mean them too but have been actually consistent if you look at what they say they want and believe you know three identity disturbance this market and persistent pattern of unstable self image or sense of self does america and most americans have a stable self-image you know impulsivity in at least two areas that are potentially self-damaging our systems are spending our national substance abuse are died in health, the things that we agree are self-evident in the point of a country. Are we doing anything that is impulsive or potentially self-damaging? Can you think of any? Recurrent suicidal behavior gestures or threats or self-mutating behavior? I mean, I don't know,
生态，忽视关于对我们公民具有破坏性的事情的明确警告。如果我们做了这些，你知道，第六条，BPD标准。情绪不稳定性，由于明显的反应性……抱歉。由于情绪的明显反应性导致的情绪不稳定性。某种某种，24小时新闻周期。长期的空虚感。第七条。
ecology, ignoring clear warnings about things that are destructive to our citizens of If we do them, you know, number six, BPD criteria. Effective instability due to a marked reactive, uh, a period. I'm sorry. Effective instability due to a marked reactivity of mood. Something something, something 24 hour news cycle. Chronic feelings of emptiness. Number seven.
看看Instagram或TikTok，尤其是那些心理健康或替代性心理健康建议。第八条，不适当的强烈愤怒或难以控制愤怒。嗯。第九条，与偏执观念或严重解离症状相关的短暂压力。有人看起来偏执吗？
Look at Instagram or TikTok, especially like some of the mental health or alternative mental health advice. Number eight, inappropriate, intense anger or difficulty controlling your anger. Hmm. Nine, transient stress related to paranoid ideation or severe dissociative symptoms. Does anybody seem paranoid?
有人看起来像是对一个真实的大问题感到非常担心，或者他们自己的痛苦，他们正在受伤。因为他们受伤了，他们可能错误地归咎于谁在伤害他们。他们认为这是一个想象中的东西，而不是一个非常明显的系统。我们在任何地方这样做吗？
Does anyone seem like they are so worried about a big problem that is real, or their own suffering and they are hurting. And so because they're hurting, they're maybe misattributing who's hurting them. They think it's an imaginary thing, you know, instead of a very obvious system. We're doing that anywhere?
你知道，有一部纪录片，乔尔·培根（Joel Bacon）很久以前制作的，叫《公司》（The Corporation）。我想培根写了书，马克·阿克巴（Mark Akbar）导演了电影。电影遵循了书的内容。但前提是对第14修正案下公司被授予法人法律权利的分析。所以培根在书中说，如果公司是一个人，那它是什么样的人？为了回答这个问题，让我们把企业行为与世界卫生组织的ICD-10或DSM中关于反社会人格障碍（即反社会者或精神病态者）的标准进行比较。
You know, there's a documentary. Joel Bacon made it a long time ago called The Corporation. I think Bacon wrote the book and Mark Akbar directed the movie. the movies, you know, like follows the book. But the premise of it is this analysis about how under the 14th Amendment, you know, corporations have been granted the legal right of being a person. And so Bacon in his book says, if a corporation is a person, what kind of person is it? And to answer that, let's compare corporate behavior to the world health organizations or the ICD10 or the DSM, their criteria for any. antisocial personality disorder, you know, being a sociopath or a psychopath.
培根和电影制作人认为，公司不仅是偶然变坏的，而且是被其治理法律制度性地强制成为精神病态者的。你知道，根据法律，公司的首要职责是股东，它必须把利润置于一切之上。如果CEO出于真正的利他主义而牺牲利润，他们可能会被起诉。电影里有一个场景，一群抗议者说，你们在制造孩子……我想可能是耐克CEO，他们说你们在柬埔寨让孩子以每小时10美分的价格编织运动鞋，
And the diagnosis that Bacon and the filmmakers argue is that the corporation is not just bad by accident, but it's institutionally mandated to be a psychopath by the laws that govern it. You know, by a law, a corporation's primary duty is to its shareholders, and it must prioritize profit above all else. And if a CEO acts out of genuine altruism at the expense of profit, they can be sued. And so there's a scene in the movie, where a bunch of protesters are like, you're making kids, I think it's like the Nike CEO maybe. And they're like, you're making kids knit sneakers in Cambodia for 10 cents an hour
他们的手指被切断了，你们太糟糕了。CEO和他的妻子邀请大家进去，和他们一起喝咖啡。CEO说，我同意你们的观点。这是错的。但如果我不这样做，他们会解雇我，找别人来做。所以你们应该让它非法化，因为所有的鞋类公司都这样做。我不知道那是不是真的是耐克CEO。我上11年级时看了那部电影，我想，不知道，20年了。总之。所以他与他们接触，就像是，
and their fingers are getting cut off and like you're terrible. And the CEO and his wife invite everyone in and they like have coffee with them. And the CEO's like, I agree with you. It's wrong. And if I don't do it, they'll fire me and they'll get somebody who will. So y'all should make it illegal because all, of the shoe companies do this. I don't know if it's really the CEO of Nike. I saw that movie when I was in 11th grade, I think, I don't know, 20 years. Anyway. Um, and so like, he engages with him. It's like,
基本上我同意你们，但我无能为力，因为我是系统的代理人。即使你们杀了我或者我走了，也会有别人来取代我的位置。所以要真正做到这一点，你必须说，我们不应该让公司为了每小时10美分制造鞋子而让孩子切断手指，这是显而易见的。也许鞋子可以贵一点，或者公司可以从那双成本一美元、售价三四百美元的乔丹鞋中少赚一点利润。他记录了这种对他人感受的冷漠，你知道，公司基本上必须这样做，因为除了钱，他们不关心任何事情。如果你要在法律上称他们为人，
basically I agree with you, but I'm powerless because I'm an agent of the system. And even if you kill me or I go away, somebody else just comes in and takes my place. So to really do this, you have to say it's self-evident that we should not let corporations make kids get their fingers cut off, making shoes for 10 cents. Maybe shoes could just cost a little. little bit more or the corporations could take a little bit less profit off, you know, the three, four hundred dollar Jordan that costs a dollar to make. And there's this callous unconcerned for the feeling of others that he documents that, you know, corporations basically have to act in because they're not concerned with anything but money. If you're going to call them a person legally,
那么让我们看看你刚才称之为人的人的心理健康状况。你知道，无法维持持久的关系。鲁莽地无视他人的安全。为了利润而欺骗、反复撒谎或诈骗，以及无法注意到或回应真相，无法体验内疚，未能遵守关于法律或行为的社会规范。我的意思是，有多少公司直接把违法、杀人或用毒药做一些可怕的事情（影响人们永远）计入他们的底线？我的意思是，这是什么？
then let's look at the mental health of what you just called a person. You know, an incapacity to maintain a during relationships. A reckless decision. regard for the safety of others, a deceitful repeated lying or conning of profit and an inability to either notice or respond to the truth, an incapacity to experiences of guilt, failure to conform to social norms with respect to law or behavior. I mean, how many corporations just build into their bottom line that they're going to break the law and that they're going to kill people or they're going to do something terrible with poison that affects, you know, people forever and I mean, what is it?
我们……你知道，当火车在俄亥俄州巴勒斯坦镇脱轨时，他们……在国内，我不是在谈论巴勒斯坦，我是在谈论俄亥俄州的巴勒斯坦，火车脱轨了，有巨大的装满聚氯乙烯的油罐车。他们没有试图清理它。他们说这太危险了。所以他们炸毁了它，让这种可怕的化学物质的黑烟冒出来，我们甚至不了解它对人们，不仅是对人们，而且对整个环境几百年来造成的影响，并流入地下水。这就是解决方案。你知道，论点不是
We lit, you know, when the train fell off the tracks in Palestine, Ohio, they, the domestically, I'm not talking about Palestine, I'm talking about the Palestine, Ohio, where the train came off the tracks, and there's giant tankers full polyvinyl chloride. They didn't try and clean it up. They said it was probably too dangerous. So they blew it up and just let black smoke of this chemical that is awful, that we don't even begin to understand what it's doing, not just to people, but to the entire environment for hundreds of years and pour into the groundwater. And that was the solution. You know, and the argument is not that
这些人是精神病态者。我的意思是，我是在谈论最高层的CEO，因为其他人不是。而是结构导致了这些事情的发生。结构本身，你知道，追求利润的法律授权导致了病态的利润追求。这迫使一个实体在没有良知的情况下行事。所以当你观察BPD时，当我说我们所有人有时都会做这些事情中的一些时。
the people are psychopaths. I mean, I'm talking about the CEO who's at the very top because the people aren't. It's that the structure makes these things happen. The structure itself, you know, the legal mandate to pursue profit at all costs creates a pathological pursuit of profit. And that forces an entity to act without a conscience. So when you're looking at BPD, when I'm saying like, we all do some of these things, some of the time.
但当我们无意识地一直使用这些防御机制时，这就是我们所做的一切，这就是我们的全部，我们有自己的另一部分，当然，你知道，那是好的，或者知道那是错的，或者想要更大的利益，但只是无法，你知道，
But when we're unconsciously doing these defense mechanisms all of the time, and it's all that we're doing, and it's all that we are, and that we have another part of ourselves, sure, you know, that's good or that knows it's wrong or that wants a greater good, but just wasn't able to, you know,
看到真相或采取行动，你知道，无论那一刻是否是更健康、有效的行为，这正是你在DBT治疗中治疗BPD时经常做的事情。是的，我们有它，但它是次要的，我们没有体现它。我们生活在防御机制中。我们谈论的是精神疾病处于这个谱系上，而不是在它的复选框里。
see the truth or act on, you know, whether it was a healthier, effective behavior in that moment, which is, you know, what you do in DBT therapy to treat BPD a lot of the time. Yeah, we have it, but it was secondary and we weren't embodying it. We were living within a defense mechanism. And we're talking about mental illness being on this spectrum instead of being in its checkbox.
在美国，有多少人处于那个谱系上？美国在这个谱系上的什么位置？嘿，伙计们。希望你们喜欢这一集。想提醒你们，如果你们有兴趣，可以去看看gethardy.com，如果想尝试一些维生素，可以使用优惠码taproot。我不是从临床医生那里听说Hardy的。我不是从广告里听说它的。我是从多个病人那里听说的。通常是多巴胺障碍患者，他们说：“嘿，我对治疗有抵抗力。我尝试了一切。”
How many people are on that spectrum in America? And where is America on that spectrum? Hey, guys. I'm hoping that you enjoyed that episode. wanted to remind you if you're in the market to check out gethardy.com and to use offer code taproot if you would like to try some vitamins. I didn't hear about Hardy from clinicians. I didn't hear about it from advertising. I heard about it from multiple patients. Usually with dopamine disorders that said, hey, I'm treatment resistant. I've tried everything.
“我去过所有这些地方，这是唯一有效的方法。”所以我查了他们，因为我对补充剂持怀疑态度，他们为证明其产品对儿童自闭症和多动症有效，支付了大量非常强有力的随机对照试验。它对很多其他事情也有效。你知道，我是临床医生，所以我的重点是心理健康。但在我们和他们做了一期播客后，Hardy给我寄了一盒。我开始服用它们，因为我服用维生素。我并没有试图治疗任何东西，但我感觉好多了。我当时想，我真的很喜欢这些。我对此很感兴趣。我要看看能不能通过我们公司把这些……
I've gone all these places and this is what worked. And so I looked them up because I was is skeptical of supplements and they had paid for a lot of really strong randomized controlled trials proving that their product worked for autism and ADHD and children. It works for a lot of other things too. You know, I'm a clinician, so my focus is on mental health. But Hardy sent me a box after we did a podcast with them. And they, uh, I started to take them because I take vitamins. I went trying to treat anything and I felt a lot better. My I was like, I really like these. I'm into it. I'm going to see if I can get these, you know, wrapped through our company. or something and my wife was making fun of me because she thought I was going to be like a
或者什么的，我妻子取笑我，因为她以为我会变成那种……
radio vitamin guy and then she started taking them and I'm pretty cheap like I don't I don't pay a lot for stuff Hardy's more expensive than CBS you can save 15% with my offer code but um I didn't like think that uh you know I just don't spend money on a lot of stuff and I do pay for Hardy because I feel like it it works um I use the same offer code that I'm offering you and um I I don't know I They have some really strong evidence on their website. If you don't want vitamins or they're not effective for you, even if the research says this thing works, if it doesn't work for you, it's your brain.
广播维生素推销员，然后她开始服用它们。我很抠门，我不为东西花很多钱。Hardy比CVS贵，你可以用我的优惠码节省15%，但是……我不认为……你知道，我只是不在很多东西上花钱，但我确实为Hardy付费，因为我觉得它有效。我使用我提供给你们的同一个优惠码，而且……我不知道，他们的网站上有一些非常有力的证据。如果你不想要维生素，或者它们对你无效，即使研究说这东西有效，如果它对你无效，那是你的大脑。
I wouldn't start buying the biggest bottle. I would get a small one and see if you notice a difference. I did. And I hope it helps. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不会开始买最大的瓶子。我会买一小瓶，看看你是否注意到区别。我注意到了。希望它有帮助。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。